lassen sie uns über die inflation
sprechen über den preisschock den wir
gerade erleben bei gas bei strom bei
sprit sie haben vor der wahl folgendes
getwittert in einem satz ganz klar sich
ausgesprochen für entlastungen bei
mittleren und kleinen einkommen
angesichts dieses inflations
preisschocks hier sehen wir noch mal den
tweet die inflation hat weiter angezogen
können wir sie uns auf sie verlassen
können sie helfen auch aktuell auch ganz
schnell ja deshalb ist es ja so richtig
dass wir den strom günstiger machen die
eeg-umlage vom strompreis unternehmen
das betrifft alle sozial schwächere bis
hin zur mittelständischen wirtschaft
darum leistung für unser land und das
muss jetzt sehr rasch angegangen rasch
ist halt sehr schwammig ne zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt haben wir noch nicht einmal
eine neue regierung und da wäre es nicht
seriös und ich glaube das erwarten die
bürgerinnen und bürger auch nicht dass
man jetzt aus der hüfte geschossen zusah
das erwarten die nicht von ihm aber das
erwarten die von der politik das ist ja
schon eine zwickmühle aktuell da sitzt
der altmaier und kann nicht mehr so
richtig und offenbar will ja wie er
vergangene woche hierbei die richtigen
fragen gesagt hat und die anderen die
können eben noch nicht weil sie noch
keine regierung sind das heißt wenn sie
wir schauen mal in das regierungspapier
ganz kurz rein an die entscheidende
stelle wo es eben um die eeg umlage geht
da schreiben sie mit ihren kollegen dass
das im laufe der legislaturperiode
passiert im laufe der legislaturperiode
also von so schnell wie möglich steht
hier aber rasch steht da nichts drin
sondern so schnell wie möglich es ist ja
sogar noch schwammiger formuliert es
gerade getan haben so richtig
verlässlich klingt das nicht dass das
hier in diesem inflations winter helfen
könnte ich bitte sie doch einfach da
etwas geduld zu haben wie sich das
konkretisiert dass herr altmaier nach
der bundestagswahl und nach vielen
jahren der regierungsverantwortung jetzt
auf diese idee kommt das können die
bürgerinnen und bürger sicherlich auch
richtig einordnen oder sie haben
natürlich nichts davon die bürger und
bürgerinnen die können das richtig
einordnen und wir haben ihnen genau das
ihm genau das vergangene woche jeweils
gehalten schauen wir mal ganz kurz
rheinländer heran was genau herr
altmaier gesagt hat er hat nämlich ihnen
ein gesprächsangebot gemacht
und ich bin der meinung wir sollten
zu beginn dieser neuen regierung die
eeg-umlage abschaffen wir können wenn
wir uns einig sind mit den koalitionären
schon bevor die neue regierung also
brauchen und sozusagen brauchten energie
gibt eben im neuen bundestag gesetze
einbringen so unten stehe als
wirtschaftsminister für gespräche zur
verfügung wenn das von den rot grünen
liberalen
koalitionspartner laden sie doch ein so
können sie heute abend machen ja ja sie
sind dabei fdp ist dabei wir
organisieren jetzt einfach mal hier den
gebrauchen und sozial das ist ja
reporter sah demokratie
ja der gipfel kam noch nicht zustande
nehmen sie das gesprächsangebot von
herrn altmaier an dann können sie
einfach zusammen werkeln der dennoch im
amt ist der es umsetzen kann gemeinsam
mit dem bundestag und sie mit der ampel
vier jahre lang hat die fdp für diese
fragen im deutschen bundestag geworben
vier jahre lang haben cdu und csu sich
ja dass sie entsprechen den sechs
angeboten nicht geöffnet peinlichen
us-bands ist jetzt ist für altmaier
das zeitfenster geschlossen jetzt geht
es ja darum eine neue regierung zu
bilden ja nur einen solchen händen da
passiert für die bürger und bürgerinnen
die jeder wahlweise zahlen vor
weihnachten halt mal gar nix herr weise
es muss ja eine neue regierung sich
bilden und sie muss ja ihre
unterschiedlichen vorhaben in einem
zusammenhang bringen so ein
finanztableau das notwendig ist wir
reden hier über zweistellige milliarden
euro beträge und klar ist das sind
jahrelang vorgetragenes anliegen der fdp
es muss bei den energiepreisen etwas
passieren dann entlasten wir die ganze
mitte der gesellschaft ich füge hinzu
man kann auch nicht eine energiewende
wollen an eine klimapolitik wollen dass
menschen auf fossile energieträger
verzichten und auf strom wechseln dann
wird der strom immer teurer das ist also
auch nicht vernünftig für die
weitergehenden ziele aber das kann man
jetzt nicht ad hoc machen und wie
ernsthaft das gesprächsangebot von herrn
altmaier ist können die menschen eben
mit blick zurück auf die letzten jahre
zu ordnen die auch richtig ein nur ist
es ja schon die situation so dass sie
nur was erreichen können in dieser
besonderen situation wenn sie eben in
einer ganz ganz großen koalition
zusammen arbeiten für die geldbeutel der
leute und da sagen sie heute machen wir
nicht weil wir wollen einen gesamtplan
ausarbeiten vor weihnachten bevor die
neue regierung steht passierte aus
unserer sicht aus ampel sich leider
nicht ich weiß gar nicht ob herr
altmaier für die gegenwärtige
bundesregierung spricht ja aber sie
machen das hier ziele als taktisches
manöver ich kann das nicht verstehen
weil das vorher war ja natürlich auch
ein taktisches manöver vielen dank aber
sagen aber das hilft alles den bürgern
halt überhaupt nichts die zahlen hat
jetzt die preise weise diese debatte ist
nicht ernsthaft und das ist auch nicht
seriös und deshalb möchte ich in diese
debatte nicht ein wer das ernsthaft und
von ganz von bürgern ist es ja was genau
die frage stellen ja und die antwort auf
die frage ist das problem wird gesehen
seit vielen jahren wirbt die fdp dafür
dass sich dort etwas ändert jetzt gibt
es die chance dass wir das was wir lange
gefordert haben jetzt umsetzen und das
ist gegenstand jetzt von den gesprächen
über eine koalition aber eben nicht vor
weihnachten beziehungsweise nicht bevor
die neue regierung geben
[Musik]